So far in the course, we've
been studying the motion
of collections of particles.
We would know like to
consider rigid bodies.
Now, rigid bodies can
be translated in space
as I move it like this.
Or we can rotate this rigid
body about some point.
I can rotate it
about the end point.
about a point which
we call the center of mass.
So I can rotate it about
the center of mass.
I can take the
rigid body and I can
rotate it about
the center of mass,
and also translate it in space.
So there's many types
of motions that we
can do with rigid bodies.
Sometimes the motions
are quite complicated.
If I spin it like that, it is
a very more complicated motion.
You can see that it's
rotating about this axis.
So what we'd like
to do now is analyze
how to think about the
motion of rigid bodies.
And what we'd like to do
is idealize our rigid body.
So even though we
looked at a rod here,
let's just draw some extended
idealized rigid body.
And let's identify two
points in that rigid body--
the j-th point and
the k-th point.
And we'll think
of our rigid body
as a bunch of point-like
particles mj and mk.
And the important thing
that defines a rigid body
is the condition that
the distance-- and we'll
draw a vector from the k-th
particle to the j-th particle.
So we'll draw that as rjk.
And actually, I'd like to
write it from the k-th particle
to the j-th particle rjk.
And our condition is that the
magnitude of this vector, which
I'll denote as rjk is constant
for all points j and k.
Now, what does that mean?
That means the distance
between any two
points in the rigid body
stays fixed no matter
how the rigid body is
moving and no matter what
two points I choose.
The distance between
any two points is fixed.
So we'll rewrite this as the
distance between any two points
is fixed.
So that doesn't change.
And that's what we call
the rigid body condition.